und ich will noch mal sagen der Text war
gerade improvisiert setze mich mal 5
Minuten an meinen Laptop dann baller ich
dir ein Back Song raus
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
es ist wahr ich habe noch nie auf diesem
Kanal eine Nutella Cheesecake gebacken
also hier ist er er ist wunderbar cremig
wunderbar Schokolade ich mit wenigen
Zutaten schnell gebacken er ist ganz
einfach also den kann wirklich jeder
backen und das einzige was etwas länger
dauert ist die Backzeit deshalb eine
Stunde im Backofen aber ihr habt so
ungefähr 10 Minuten Zubereitungszeit für
Boden und Füllung dann kommt deine Ofen
muss Auskühlen Schokosoße drauf und
fertig ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten
für den Boden das sind nämlich nur drei
für den Keksboden nehme ich 200 Gramm
Butterkekse 120 g Butter und 30 Gramm
Kakao das hier geht jetzt ganz einfach
ihr schmilzt einfach die Butter ich
nehme dafür schon mal eine große
Schüssel die groß genug ist damit da
auch die Butterkekse gleich reinpassen
dass ich später nicht sage hätte ich
doch eine größere Schüssel genommen ja
ja
deswegen nehme ich hier die
emailschüssel denn die kann einfach auf
den Herd
frag mich übrigens in letzter Zeit immer
ganz viele was ist hier für eine Matte
ist und zwar habe ich ja ein
Induktionskochfeld das bedeutet das
Kochfeld an sich wieder nicht heiß
sondern wird nur warm durch die
rückwärme der Töpfe sind magnetisches
Kochfeld und wenn ihr ein
Induktionskochfeld habt könnt ihr diese
induktionsmatte verwenden die euren Herd
als eure Kochfläche verkratzern schützt
so eine Anti Rutsche Unterlage das heißt
wenn ich hier einen Topf ein Gefäß oder
eben eine Schüssel drauf stelle dann
verrutscht den ich und ich kann dann
auch mit einer Hand rühren mit der
anderen Hand was anderes machen denn
ansonsten rutschen Töpfe immer schnell
hin und her und die schützt quasi den
Topf vor Kratzern und man kann sie
später dann auch benutzen als Anti
hitzeunterlage als antirutschunterlage
das ist die Matte da werde ich meinen
Stories aber ganz viel nämlich danach
gefragt die Butter schmilzt jetzt hier
bei mittlerer Hitze nicht kochen lassen
braucht man gar nicht da spritzt es nur
unnötig rum das wollen wir nicht und
solange zerbrösel ich die Kekse da
könnte jetzt den nehmen ihr könnt sie
mit den Händen zerbröseln
ihr könnt sie in eine Tüte packen mit
dem ausrollstab rüber Rollen oder ihr
nehmt einfach den Mixer kommt mit so
machen wir das jetzt hier
gell
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo Papa
ist
mache ich immer einen Kaffee jetzt habt
ihr hier die flüssige Butter die
zerbröselten Kekse und
und damit das Ganze ein schöner
Schokoboden wird packe ich jetzt hier
noch Kakao mit rein
lasst euch nicht vom Papa irritiere da
weiß noch zehn Jahren manchmal immer
noch nicht dass ich Videos mache aber
ich finde es voll süß
der kommt da eine trinkt da was dann
geht ein bisschen im Garten
und da hält sich hier im Team dass ich
immer süß er stört auch nicht nee das
stört auch nie Papa ist süß
Papa ist der beste
[Musik]
ziemlich hier den Springform Boden und
zwar ist es der 25 cm Boden da kommt die
Backfolie rein und dann der Tortenring
es klappt auch ohne Springform Boden auf
jeden Fall mit dem Tortenring und dem
geraden Blech mit dem Premium Blech aber
wenn ihr das so macht dann seid ihr auf
jeden Fall auf Nummer sicher das nichts
ausläuft denn die käsekuchenmasse die
später schon ein bisschen flüssig aber
wie gesagt wenn ich früher New York
Cheesecakes gemacht habe dann hat es
auch ohne spring vom Boden geklappt aber
so ist man immer safe das nächste
kommt jetzt hier die Bröselmasse rein
und dann wird sie schön flach gedrückt
entweder mit einem Löffel mit einem Glas
oder mit einer burgerpresse
wenn er dann schön glatt ist einfach zur
Seite stellen und dann werden wir schon
mal den nutella-masse machen denn dann
kommt die noch oben drauf und der kann
schon direkt in den Backofen also das
meiste was man hier machen muss ist
eigentlich nur warten während dem Ofen
backt der Rest ist echt easy peasy ganz
einfach also die Zutaten für die Nutella
Füllung
dafür verwende ich 750 Gramm Frischkäse
300 Gramm Nutella 50g Zucker 40g Kakao 5
Eier und Vanilleextrakt hier jetzt
einfach drauf achten dass alle Zutaten
Zimmertemperatur haben dann lässt sich
es besser verarbeiten und auch hier ist
es richtig einfach ihr packt nämlich
zuerst mal den Frischkäse mit Nutella in
eine Rührschüssel
und ich muss sagen die Zutaten an sich
sind auch überschaubar drei Zutaten für
den Boden und eins zwei drei vier fünf
sechs
praktische jetzt keine Zutaten ne das
hat mir immer da sechs Zutaten für die
käsekuchenmasse und dann kommen nur noch
zwei Zutaten für oben drauf
der perfekte Cheesecake ich weiß gar
nicht warum ich den nicht schon früher
gemacht habe aber gestern dachte ich so
ich habe noch keinen Nutella Cheesecake
oder jetzt Nutella nehmen oder eine
andere Nuss-Nougat Creme ist natürlich
euch überlassen ich muss tatsächlich
dazu sagen Nutella an sich ist ich so
jetzt nicht mehr so gerne da gibt's
finde ich tolle Alternativen ohne
Palmfett richtig gute qualitative Nuss
Nougat Cremes
aber in so einem Cheesecake finde in
einem Toast auch ich habe es eigentlich
nie daheim die Kinder waren so was wenn
Nutella zu Hause und ich habe gedacht ja
ich backe mir Nutella Cheesecake und sie
freuen sich das ein bisschen was übrig
bleibt irgendwo muss man halt auch mal
die Kirche im Dorf lassen gell
also Nutella dazu und schön verrühren
und beim verrühren darauf achten eine
Schüssel nehmen die groß genug ist und
darauf achten dass er keine Luft
einschlagt denn dann reißt er auf
sondern dass er es nur cremig rührt bei
niedriger Stufe
[Musik]
oh mann hätte ich doch eine größere
Schüssel genommen ich kann auch
sonnenstürmer gut abschätzen
du weißt doch ganz genau dass die
Schüssel zu klein ist doch immer wieder
tust du dem gleichen
Fehler
dann Küchenschrank ist voller bloß so
schön
doch nie denkst du mit du bist so ein
dumm sein
also Apache wenn du mal eine
back-szene rausbringen will
kontaktiere mich einfach
aber ich muss sagen es hat geklappt
und ich will nur mal sagen der Text war
gerade improvisiert setze mich mal 5
Minuten an meinen Laptop dann baller ich
dir ein Back Song raus
so wie mein endersong
so und jetzt
bei niedriger Stufe die Eier nach und
nach dazugeben
schafft sie es oder schafft sie es nicht
ohne Kleckern
kann man jetzt im Video eine Abstimmung
machen
[Musik]
ich hasse es
wie schüttet man elegant Eier hinein
[Musik]
ich will einfach immer gerne ohne Eier
backen aber es geht halt nicht wenn man
so gewisse Effekte haben will im
Sandkuchen
Benutzer der Eier Fan
[Musik]
oh ja
ihr basteln möchte ein Leckerli haben
[Musik]
ich liebe dich
mein süßes kleines Katzenbaby
jetzt gut
hallo
mein kleiner Mausi
was haben die damit ihren komischen
Kameras ja
spielen Mama geht Hände waschen
echt blöd dass er jetzt weg ist
ich glaube ich überlebt es nicht
ich hoffe sie fliegt früh raus dann
geht's wieder Kuchen
nein wir wollen ja dass sie weiterkommt
also ruft für Sie an drückt er die
Daumen
es gibt einfach mal Kuchen
dann habe ich jetzt hier die
käsekuchenmasse meinen vorbereiteten
Boden und ich glaube ich muss auch mal
meinen New York Cheesecake Rezept
erneuern denn damals habe ich noch den
Boden vorgebacken aber warum eigentlich
macht den Boden Creme drauf ab in den
Ofen fertig
keine Wartezeit kein heißes Blech in die
Hand nehmen es wird hier die Masse
einfach eingefüllt und jetzt bisschen
klopfen
da seht ihr hier an der Oberfläche
nämlich wie die Luftbläschen entweichen
und aufplatzen und dann bei 160 Grad
Ober-Unterhitze 15 Minuten vorbacken die
Hitze runterstellen auf 130 und dann
noch mal ungefähr 70 Minuten backen nach
dem Backen lasse ich hinter dem Ofen
bisschen abkühlen und hole ihn dann erst
raus
[Musik]
ich freue mich auf den Kuchen
jetzt ist der Cheesecake gebacken ich
habe ihnen wie gesagt im Ofen auskühlen
lassen für etwa eine halbe Stunde habe
ihn dann rausgenommen und jetzt ist er
hier noch etwas lauwarm der Kuchen ist
super der reißt auch nicht ein wenn ihr
wirklich drauf achtet dass die
käsekuchenmasse Raumtemperatur hat also
der Frischkäse holt den also wirklich
rechtzeitig aus dem Kühlschrank raus
dann sieht es super aus aber selbst wenn
er einreist ist gar nicht schlimm denn
es kommt sowieso eine Ganache drauf
dafür nehme ich 100 g Sahne und 200 g
Zartbitterschokolade es wird die Sahne
aufgekocht dann schalte ich den Herd aus
würde Schokolade ein fertig
den Cheesecake lasse ich jetzt mal noch
da drinnen der darf noch ein bisschen
Auskühlen jetzt kommt hier die Ganache
drauf und die streiche ich nicht ganz
bis zum Rand sondern ich lasse dann 1 cm
kommt dann gefällt mir es richtig gut
[Musik]
finde ich echt zurückhalten den nicht
sofort so löffeln
das sieht so gut aus
ich meine ihr könnt auch die Ganache
halbieren und eine dünnere
Schokoladenschicht machen aber das
empfehle ich euch nicht denn ich glaube
das passt wirklich perfekt
ich lasse jetzt ein bisschen abkühlen
dass die gerne ein bisschen fest wird
aber wenn ihr ihn jetzt anschneiden
würdet dann läuft die sogar noch am Rand
runter
ob ich das trotzdem so 10 Minuten im
Kühlschrank
dann jetzt aus der Form gelöst auf eine
schöne Platte gesetzt dann probieren wir
diesen Kuchen
[Musik]
Timmy möchtest du Kuchen probieren ja
egal wo du magst hier noch flüssiges
Wetter in der Mikrowelle
der ist so gut und am besten tut ihr mir
den Gefallen und esst den nicht
Kühlschrank kalt sondern so ein bisschen
zimmerwarm
das noch besser
und dann noch
bisschen Nutella drauf
und jetzt ist die Glasur noch nicht ganz
fest wenn sie fest wird euch schon ein
bisschen knackig aber ich mag so viel
lieber wenn sie noch ein bisschen
flüssiges
[Musik]
hier ein Stück
silence Verkostung
[Musik]
das cremig gell
ich muss gar nicht dass es so geht ja
also
ein Kuchen
da also ich beherrsche mich ja schon
immer ne beim Essen soll ich es schon
sehr gesund ich trink immer Wasser und
es viel Sellerie und Gemüse und Obst und
echt wenig Süßes weil ich nie Lust drauf
habe aber der Kuchen
[Musik]
wow da gönne ich mir jetzt auch ein
riesen Stück so ein richtig großes Stück
der so saftig das kann man schon essen
gesund ja dann genieße ich den auch
falls ihr diesen Nutella Cheesecake
ausprobieren wollt also nicht falsch
wenn ihr ihn ausprobiert ihr müsst
nämlich denn wow Hammer
geht einfach auf sallys-blog.de oder in
die App macht am besten gleich das
doppelte Rezept denn ein Kuchen wird
nicht ausreichend weil er ebenso gut ist
oder
[Musik]
wahnsinnig gut also probiert ihn aus
Schokoladenliebhaber lieben diesen
Kuchen
bis bald
also Tim du hast jetzt die Wahl zwischen
du behältst ihn einfach komplett oder
ich teile mit meinem Team ich überlasse
es einfach dir
es tut mir leid aber
ich habe heute leider kein Stück Kuchen
für dich
danke bis dann so streiten sie sich um
den Kuchen ich überlege mir das dann
noch ja mal gucken was es gibt
[Musik]